hello i'm dr marcia pearce i'm an
assistant professor in the department of
pharmacology at midwestern university in
downers grove illinois
and i'd like to thank you for joining my
talk today titled pre-clinical
evaluation of novel oxytocin analogues
for the potential treatment of social
behavioral deficits
at the end of this talk today i hope
that you will be able to
describe the drug development process
and timeline
identify challenges associated with
neuropharmacological drug development
differentiate between agonists partial
agonists and antagonists
discuss how drug effects on cellular
signaling and neuronal morphology may
relate
to the physiological and social
behavioral changes at the organismal
level
so the drug development timeline and
process how do we get a drug to market
basic research generally identifies
chemicals through synthesis
screening or examination and medicinal
chemists
will identify and modify a number of
novel structures that may have
activity at our receptor of interest and
then
we look at the metabolism and the
distribution properties of this in
primary cell culture first
if these any of these 10 to 25 000
initial hits that we have um have the
appropriate properties that we're
interested in
then they move on to pre-clinical
testing in animals
in animals they are generally first
screened in one rodent type
such as mouse and then moved on to one
non-rodent animal such as rabbit
and of these 10 to 20 screenings that
would get
chemical screenings that would get moved
from the initial synthesis and screening
we want to look for a number of things
including carcinogenicity
genotoxicity reproductive toxicity
as well as assessing if they are safe
and effective in
the animal model if one of these drugs
is found to be safe and effective in
both a rodent and non-rodent model
then the investigator files an
investigational new drug application
at this time the fda approves and
determines if
this can be used in for clinical trials
in humans
clinical trials in humans are then
broken down generally into three phases
the first phase has a very small number
of participants and it's used to test
for safety of the drug next they look
in a slightly larger group to see if
it's efficacious
and finally in large scale studies they
look to see
if it's worth the potential risks or
side effects associated with the drug
if all of these are found to be
safe effective and worth the risk then a
new drug application
is filed with
the fda and then is analyzed
and if approved they begin
registration for their product and post
marketing surveillance which can last up
to 20 years
and looks for additional side effects
that may be associated with these
drugs so as you can see from the initial
10 to 25 000 chemical screenings you see
a great attrition
occurring over each of these stages to
get one single drug to market
neuroscience drug development is
particularly fraught with
issues because it's not as simple as
say looking at a cholesterol drug where
you can just look at the
cholesterol numbers of ldl and hdl or a
blood pressure medication where you're
simply screening
to address if there's a decrease in
blood pressure
they have a very low success rate due to
a number of complicating factors
including that nearly all central
nervous system therapeutics treat
symptoms rather than modifying the
disease
diagnoses of these cns disorders are
often based on
clusters of clinical symptoms rather
than on objective laboratory measures
clinical trials often assess subjective
measures
that are fraught with placebo and nocebo
fx
nocebo effects being effects that are
expected
psychologically to be even though the
person is receiving a placebo
and these complexities result in larger
longer and more expensive clinical
trials than for all
other medical indications at a time
when neuroscience and clinical
drug development is sorely needed due to
an
aging population and increased burn
health care burden
drug companies are largely exiting the
neuroscience drug development process
so we need novel ways to assess
and identify chemicals that may be of
interest for them
to provide better opportunities for
neuroscience drug development
so why am i interested in the oxytocin
and arginine and
and vasopressin family this family is
highly evolutionarily conserved
in invertebrates there's a single
analog associated with a number of these
various species
including anapressin in your anilids and
nematocin
in your nematodes as we look into
gastropods we see conopressin
and in insects enotosin
however in about 600 million years ago
in
fish there appears to be a gene
duplication which is the first time
where we see
both an oxytocin analog and a
vasopressin analog
in your vertebrates at this time in
telos we see
isotocin and vasotosine
when we get to a's reptilia and
amphibians
we see mesotocin and vasotozin by the
time we get to humans
it's oxytocin and arginine and
vasopressin
although pigs have lysopressin and new
world monkeys have a
great variety of various oxytocin
analogs which i'll talk about on the
next slide
and finally in marsupials there's
another gene duplication where they
generally have
two oxytocin analogs and three
vasopressin analogs
we're particularly interested in the
various
new world monkey analogs because as you
can see with figure a here
leucine oxytocin is the consensus
mammalian sequence
and then there is proline oxytocin in
blue
and it has a proline proline helix at
the tail
that causes a kink making this a much
more stable analog
than the leucine oxytocin that is is
generally found in humans
additional ones that we see are alanine
eight oxytocin
threonine eight oxytocin and
phenylalanine two oxytocin
two additional analogs that have
recently been found
are val3 pro eight oxytocin and val3
leuk8 oxytocin
so if we look at this circle figure on
the right hand side
there are three major clades of new
world monkeys
in your seba day which is primarily
marked in blue here
all of them express the pro-eight
oxytocin which has a much longer
half-life
except one species of sanguinis which
has a val-3 pro-8 oxytocin
that was identified by vargas pinella
in our achilla day there is
quite a range including the val3 lew8
oxytocin in a howler monkey species
uh phenylalanine oxytocin
threonine oxytocin and leucine 8
oxytocin
and then in cbd we can see again the
alanine eight oxytocin
and other various uh forms
as we get to our old world monkeys and
our hominidae day
and our proto-lemurs
we can see that leucine oxytocin is
entirely expressed in these other groups
additionally evolutionary preservation
of function
is seen with these oxytocin receptors so
oxytocin
receptors are expressed in areas in the
brain
that are the primary modality of social
investigation
and this supports the hypothesis that
oxytocin receptors act
to regulate social behavior and approach
so if we look at t lost we see
the primary expression of oxytocin
receptors in the forebrain and midbrain
and primitive amygdala regions whereas
if we look in songbirds we see this
expression extended to the vocal and
auditory input
areas which is their primary modality of
social behavior
whereas in rodents we also see this
expression
in the olfactory area which is their
primary modality of social investigation
and as we move to primates
we see that it is expressed in the
nucleus basalis of minor and in the
superior colliculus
areas that are very important for visual
input and processing
together these suggest that the areas
that are involved
in social behavior and processing of
how we interact with others is very
important
based on where the oxytocin receptor is
expressed
so oxytocin and vasopressin receptors
are expressed both in the social brain
network
and perturbations in oxytocin and or
oxytocin receptor
results in social behavioral and memory
deficits
oxytocin and vasopressin are associated
with a number of psychopathologies
including autism spectrum disorder
anxiety
post-traumatic stress disorder and
schizophrenia
a number of genetic and epigenetic as
well as
social and physiological stimuli affect
oxytocin and vasopressin receptor
expression
additionally we can modify this using
psychopharmacotherapy
by treating with oxytocin or vasopressin
analogs
unfortunately because oxytocin and
vasopressin do not easily
cross the blood-brain barrier have poor
bio-availability
and very short half-lives currently
intranasal oxytocin
application that is the only option for
treatment in
humans and higher vertebrates however
all there are a number of peripheral
drugs that are currently in use for the
oxytocin and vasopressin system
now oxytocin and vasopressin are
expressed in the hypothalamic and limbic
circuitries
and they act essentially as a yin and
yang for
behaviors oxytocin is associated with
anxiolytic behavior which is a decrease
in anxiety
active stress coping and stress
resilience whereas vasopressin
is associated with hyper anxiety or
anxiogenic behaviors
anxiety disorders passive stress coping
depression and high stress
susceptibility
because these uh different
peptides can act at each other's
receptors
how they interact with the receptors has
a large
effect on whether they are tilting
towards the oxytocin or towards the
vasopressin
cell signaling pathways
so the research goal for my work here is
to evaluate the structural
which is neurite outgrowth and
connectivity and functional
or cellular signaling effects of
oxytocin analogues in urine
primary neuronal cultures and
human-derived neuronal-like cells
the reason that i select a mirroring
primary neuronal culture
is because practical and ethical
considerations obviously preclude
the use of human neuron primary neuronal
cultures
but animal models do provide an
option for studying this as a
pre-clinical
test however there is only 92 percent
homology
between the human oxytocin receptor and
the murine oxytocin receptor
so i also want to look at cellular
signaling patterns
in human-derived shs-y5y
neuronal like cells to address what
cellular
signaling differences we may see between
the two models
so obviously because leucine oxytocin on
the left here
is the endogenous both human and mouse
uh endogenous oxytocin variant
we are also we're going to use that as
our primary
variant and then we will look at proline
oxytocin which has
the red proline connected right next to
the
seventh proline that provides that
polyproline helix that makes it have a
much
more stable half-life and
structural stability we also are looking
at val3 pro eight
because it has that same extended
half-life
and we're comparing it with abp because
arginine vasopressin is also
expressed endogenously in both mice and
humans
the way that we first analyze the
cellular signaling pathways is using
high throughput calcium mobilization
assays so we use
flow eight acetyl methyl esterase a
fluorescent dye
that we then incubate our cells for
one hour and then we insert them into
what's called
a fluorescence imaging plate reader 2
and that will
read a baseline reading for the first
minute of
our cells and then it will
read a fluorescence increase after it
puts
the drug in all 98 wells of our plate
and from there we can then analyze the
different
um cell signaling patterns based on
dose of specific analogs that are put
into
the slipper
so first i want to discuss drug potency
and efficacy
because these are things that we'll be
looking at throughout the rest of the
talk
potency is the concentration at which
the drug produces the half
maximal effect or the ec50
so if you look at figure a here
on the left you see that the percent
maximal effect is on the y-axis
and the log of your drug of interest is
on the x-axis
so in this case drug x is less shifted
from drug y
so it would have a more potent
or a higher ec 50
than your drug y
we also look at maximal efficacy which
reflects the capacity of a drug to
activate a receptor
and as you can see in figure b here then
we look at the percent of maximal effect
over the dose and as you can see with
the red
drug x it is not only more potent
for the ec 50 but it also has
a higher maximal effect so it's more
efficacious
than drug y listed in purple here
so this is some data collected by a
colleague
who was looking in cells that expressed
human vasopressin receptor 1a and as
expected arginine vasopressin is its
endogenous analog so that would be more
potent
but it was also more efficacious than
both your leucine or your proline
oxytocin
as you can see with the arginine
vasopressin in black here and the
leucine and proline in red and blue
something very interesting that they saw
in this data though was
that if they used the leucine and
proline
in combination with arginine and
vasopressin
they actually saw that it acted as an
antagonist
as you can see in the triangles that are
not filled in and the circles that are
not filled in
here suggesting that both leucine
and proline at the human vasopressin
receptor
can act to potentially block the
anxiogenic effects
in addition to what we already see
in their anxiolytic effects at the
oxytocin receptor
so first we're going to look at the
effects in the human derived
neuronal shsy5y cell line
which has expresses the oxytocin
receptor
and has the capacity for neurite
outgrowth
and so in figure a here we use the
arginine vasopressin and we saw a very
small response
in relation to the concentrations of
arginine and vasopressin
whereas we saw a slightly larger
response in b for the leucine oxytocin
so you as you compare the leucine
oxytocin in blue in figure c
to the argenine vasopressin you can see
that there was a much larger response
as would be expected if this is at an
oxytocin receptor
however we wanted to confirm that our
arginine vasopressin
peptide was good so we chose
the human oxytocin receptor cho cells
which overexpressed the oxytocin
receptor to analyze the effects in
figure
d here with argon and vasopressin and
e was leucine oxytocin and as you can
see in figure f
the blue and green again you expect to
see
oxytocin as more potent and
similar efficacy in this case
to the arginine and vasopressin but you
would expect it to be much more potent
at the oxytocin receptor which is what
we see suggesting that this is not a
problem
with our peptide
so next we wanted to assess if this is
occurring at the oxytocin receptor the
vasopressin receptor or both
so in our shsy5y cells in figure a
here you see the raw data with our
leucine 8 oxytocin
and in figure b it's our leucine 8
oxytocin
with pretreated with our vasopressin 1a
receptor inhibitor
sr49059 which had
no major effect on the response
however in figure c we pretreated
with our oxytocin receptor inhibitor
l371257
and as you can see that largely blocked
the total response
and in figure d here that shows that
leucine oxytocin
and leucine oxytocin with our
vasopressin receptor sr49059
showed very little difference in
response
whereas with our leucine oxytocin
and our oxytocin receptor inhibitor l
three seven one two five seven
it completely abolished the response
these data demonstrate that this is
occurring through the oxytocin receptor
which is consistent with microarray data
that suggested that shsy5y cells express
oxytocin receptor but not phasopressing
receptor 1a
next we wanted to look at our three
oxytocin peptides to see
if they induce calcium mobilization at
the oxytocin receptor in shsy5y cells
so in figure a here again we're looking
at
the response data for leucine a oxytocin
figure b here is proline 8 oxytocin
figure c is val 3 pro 8 oxytocin
and figure d here shows the potency and
efficacy
of these three various oxytocin analogs
and at this point
all three have relative potency and
overlapping efficacies
demonstrating no statistically
significant
uh difference in either potency or
efficacy between the three
next we wanted to assess whether this
was due to
extracellular calcium coming into the
cell via calcium channels
or intracellular calcium being mobilized
via the endoplasmic reticulum so
in figure a here we show the leucine
oxytocin response
in figure b we have the leucine oxytocin
response that was pre-treated
with one micromolar of fafsa gargan
which
causes a decrease in the release of your
calcium from your endoplasmic reticulum
and as you can see in figure c here the
leucine oxytocin was primarily abolished
with the pre-treatment of fafsa gargan
suggesting
that this is intracellular calcium
mobilization in our shsy5y cells
in figures d e and f we're looking at
the same
except with prolene oxytocin at this
time in my lab we are currently
assessing val 3 pro8 unfortunately we
did not have the data at the time of
this recording
next we wanted to look at effects
on neurite outgrowth and figure a
here shows an shsy 5y
cell that is grown in control media
and pre-treated with just our control
dmso and as you see in figure b
then that has been traced using image j
with neuron j
fiji package and in figure c here
you see one it pretreated for 24 hours
with one micromolar of leucine 8
oxytocin
and in figure d that then is drawn using
the image j
with neuron j plug-in and so
initial data from this is
we have analyzed 20 cells so far or
two experiments worth for the leucine
oxytocin
and ten cells or one uh
experiment worth with the proline
oxytocin for each dose
and as you can see in figure a with our
leucine oxytocin
between negative 6.5 and negative 5.5
which is 300 nanomolar to
3 micromolar we do see what appears to
be
a increase in the right outcomes
we also see an increase in the number of
branches now that's branching anywhere
on the cell
whereas in figure c the number of
processes
is just the number of branches coming
directly off the soma
and with a much smaller pool you're
looking at preliminary data here for the
proline oxytocin
for d e and f which also appear to
suggest
that we may see these similar outgrowth
patterns in the shsy5y
cells as well
now those cells don't have the same
dynamic responses that you see in
primary dissociated
hippocampal cultures so this is
days in vitro one of our marine primary
dissociated hippocampu culture
and these cultures make connections and
then
have rhythmic calcium oscillations which
enable neuroplasticity and enhance
connections between the cells
and so first here we are looking at
leucine oxytocin and figure a
is our control where you see the
rhythmic calcium oscillations
and our just our control locks buffer
being
delivered at one minute in figure b
you see 10 nanomolar of leucine 8
oxytocin and
increasing doses in c b and e
and then finally in f you see our
positive control varatrovin
and what we can see in figures d and e
is that at one micromolar and 10
micromolar there appears to be an
increase in the calcium size with early
print
calcium oscillation size of early
preliminary data
we've also assessed this preliminarily
with
proline oxytocin and have seen a similar
response
we need to replicate this data a couple
of more times
as well as looking at the same processes
using the val3 pro 8
in hopes to see how this may affect the
calcium oscillations in the primary
marine hippocampal
we will then test it with the various
inhibitors
and further parse out how the cellular
signaling pathways are working in these
cells
so in summary this project combines
assessing
structural or neurite outgrowth and
connectivity
and functional cellular signaling assays
to potentially provide
insights into mechanisms that modulate
social behavior
knowledge of how oxytocin alters
neuronal structure and function
has the potential to both identify
mechanisms that produce social
dysfunction
and inform the development of
oxytocin-mediated therapeutic agents
and as you can see these are very
preliminary studies
that i'm currently working on in my lab
but
we do have future directions to complete
the ongoing analyses
with these oxytocin analogs in both our
shsy5y and our primary marine cultures
additionally we'd like to examine the
structural and functional
characteristics of additional oxytocin
analogs
and finally we would like to cross the
oxytocin receptor
expressing gfp mouse line with a mouse
model of autism spectrum disorder to
examine
oxytocin analog therapeutic effects on
social behaviors
cellular signaling and neurite structure
in a single model
at this time i would like to thank all
of the people that have helped
contribute to this work
including my laboratory students nishi
vadam
disney panicker supriya bhuvanagiri
ashley gore aries aziz and marissa gare
i'd also like to thank the department of
pharmacology at midwestern university
midwestern university college of
graduate studies intramural research
funding who has funded this study and
i'd like to thank lab roots for giving
me the opportunity to
present my data thank you